we are old long friends we would go wave
our attacks and dinners so many parties
we've gone to the Oscars a bunch of time
we did one time a couple years ago I had
an Oscar party he had no intention of
going to the Vanity Fair party mm-hmm
and you and Liza insisted I go up and
put on my tux this is Liza Minnelli Yeah
right not my wife yeah this is when I
was dating her yeah my wife Liza we went
oh I remember seeing when when Liza was
performing once mmm and you and I went
to see her when you were first dating
Liza Minnelli and so revved up she was
in New York her arm flew right off now
curiosity also I think we have a picture
of us together at the Vanity Fair party
once there we are
[Applause]
do you have do you have an Oscar you've
done so much you've accomplished so much
do you have one I have a date I'm Oscar
[Laughter]
I was told this year I kind of like that
I'm two films away from making the in
memoriam package so I but I went to the
Vanity Fair party this year stormy
Daniels was my plus one
no nice real name by the way really
stormy Rabinowitz
she's a little we're old chums we used
to do Jazzercise together and no she as
melodia says of stormy Daniels better
her than me you know but listen what a
party that is somebody celebrity did you
go this year I did not go this year how
come not invited no no I was invited my
kids had no interest in the Austrian
they desperately wanted I had promised
them to take him to German gee I did so
I went to Jumanji and because everyone's
at the Oscars it was completely empty
but my kid I was a hero to my kids well
that's because you're a good dad yeah
I'm a good dad no I mean listen it's
amazing who's at that Vanity Fair it's
everyone and people you don't expect
Jeff Sessions was there not to party he
was just deporting the bus boys Harrison
Ford crashed the party oh yeah just
right in this plane oh for god sake
amazing party please yeah Sarah Huckabee
Sanders oh yeah yeah and you know first
I didn't see her but I just heard that
voice saying do I look like I ordered a
side salad you know
she looks like the before picture of a
Zoloft
look at Denny's waitress would give you
if you asked if the eggs were cage free
[Laughter]
how many about how do you feel about the
films this year the films that were
nominated ooh I I liked them I loved
phantom thread I thought that was
fabulous and I that break great Paul
Thomas Anderson I loved the shape of
water mm-hmm which brings new meaning
the idea she'll have the fish you know
Dunkirk if I want to see a bunch of dog
fights I'd go to Andy's house I don't
and you can make some money yeah no I
got there I thought there were Patrick's
I mean basically the foreign films were
tremendous or as the Trump White House
calls them [ __ ] films yeah it's a
new category foreign he's doing a good
job he's doing a very good job yeah I
think you're from Canada Canadians happy
with our president oh why wouldn't they
be 25 percent say their best friend
ya know yeah he's it's I don't know I'm
not a big politician but there almost
seems like there's no rhyme or reason to
his thinking oh yeah it's all gonna work
out just fine I guess so stormy told me
an interesting thing that when she about
the president but if she say well this
is I mean I don't know if I'm not
revealing too much she said during sex
he screams out his own name which I
think
all right
you